hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on a foreigner yet and today
we have some small and for to talk about
but it's all some big news about the
roadmap of for honor for January 2019 so
let's get started with that like the V
if we do enjoy subscriber for new I
cover the informational side I'll for
honor that being balanced changes hero
updates patch notes leaks all the good
stuff so let's get started with today's
video as always guys happy new years
this is the first video I've made in
2019 so I didn't get a chance say happy
nears so Happy New Year's guys hope you
guys did enjoy that and as well I just
read the comments on this write a post
from the Ubisoft devs and stuff like
that and they're most likely not going
to be a stream next which would be
tomorrow cuz I'm uploading this on my on
Wednesday so January 3rd there will not
be a stream but there should be one
January 10th so very interesting stuff
but anyway let's get into today's news
so like I said we're gonna be talking
about the road map we're gonna be going
through all of it so on screen you'll
see the road map now January 3rd we have
memory block 3 which is the event 1 of
the event challenges which you have to
do in the new event game mode pretty
cool on top of there being a new one
called the Animus redacted live that's a
new arcade quest so definitely hop on
with that there most likely will be Ezio
and they're just seeing as we had a
Cesare from last week's that'd be really
cool to see on top of that the fourth we
will have the extra loot fest January
for it so if you want to get some new
loot and you want to get it all the
quickest and all that you can obviously
check my video being the I in the top
right you can also use this extra loop
fest on the 4th which should come out
Friday so you can get some more lutes
you don't have to pay steel for it come
into 10th we have dance of the winter
solstice another arcade quest put some
content of the week which is should when
the dev streams should come back of
course so then obviously though it's a
show the content of the week during the
stream so that's what my presumption is
and what the devs have said so hopefully
we'll be getting some streams on the
January 10th which would be really
interesting as for the content of the
week nobody knows but I'll get into that
a little bit later in the video next up
we have the ranked warrior challenge
with some double xp rewards the Sal Mesa
celebrations as well so more content the
breach Slayer challenge the Vorta girl
reveal livestream the broken oath arcade
quests and some content that same week
the ranked Vanquisher challenged the day
after and the Vorta girl reveal stream
on the 31st so lots of stuff to take in
personally for me i from what i've done
i've obviously covered this game for
almost
three years now it's gonna be three
years in February and I've noticed that
the developers like to release the
executions a week before the reveal of
the character not now I'm not talking
the reveal stream but the actual release
date so my presumption is that we're
gonna be getting executions on January
24th which is the exact same day that
we're getting the Vorta core reveal
stream so definitely be looking out for
that like I said this is an assumption
this could be totally wrong we could be
getting it next week or the week after
that no one really clue but I do hope
that this is going to be some packed
info for the month of January are gonna
be seeing more dagger the sword and
board character the night that we saw in
the leaft gameplay
yeah but I'm very excited to see what's
gonna happen during the reveal stream
it's gonna be Vorta gur i don't know if
that's going to be his actual name but
that'd be really sick if it was he's
gonna be the sword in board or sword and
shield character for the Knights for the
year 3 in the first character of year 3
as well with the others following in the
later seasons a lot of people in the
comments we're talking about armor that
we're gonna be getting for next season
and if that even happens it'll most
likely be on the 17th or the 10th I
doubt we're gonna be getting those on
the 24th as well that'd be too much
packed info so almost if there is gonna
be new weapons and new armor it'll
either be revealed on the 17th and maybe
the 24th but that might be a slight
chance but let me know what you guys
think I'm very excited for the vertigo
reveal cannot wait to hop on and play
this character when he releases on the
31st of January and that is also for
season past people if you bought the
year pass if you did not buy the year 3
pass you will have to buy him with steal
and you will only be able to play him
until after February 14 to two weeks
after everybody else gets it hey guys
hope you guys did enjoy the video like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I covered the informational
side of foreigner that being bounced
changes hero updates patch notes leaks
all that good stuff my two most recent
videos will be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out I think I just
hope ever great is today thank you for
watching the video and peace out